bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
championnat du monde féminin 2016 mariam
auzits choc face à l'ifan ou la chinoise
on est donc dans la sixième partie
marjanovic ou qui est toujours mené d'un
point mais après avoir eu deux fois les
noirs aux parties 4 et 5 1 se retrouve
de nouveau donc avec les blancs et donc
la maintenant dans une une opportunité
de pouvoir essayer de revenir au score
donc tout est encore ouvert l'a montré
de belles choses à des parties
précédentes donc on espère laquelle va
faire une belle partie donc voyons ça
tout de suite marjanovic redémarre avec
le cadre elle revient à 2,4 après avoir
un petit peu dévié
histoire de se refaire une santé après
sa défaite ici e4 au début ouvert que va
faire ou ifan et bien eu cinq encore la
mène apparemment symétrie cavaliers
trois cavaliers c6 alors est-ce qu'on va
avoir droit de nouveau à la fameuse gruy
lopez 1 de la fameuse partie espagnole
luis lopez ou est-ce qu'on va pourquoi
pas donc on en avait parlé un peu avoir
le coup c4 une italienne
eh bien regardez up eh bien oui c'est
bien une italienne cette fois alors on
l'appelle italienne alors pour des
raisons que sans doute gréco avait dû le
jouer souvent
mais rue lopez est déjà au xvième siècle
dans son dans son fameux livre en fête
analyse beaucoup ce début donc on
retrouve beaucoup de parties avec ça
donc c'est quand même un début qui était
qui était très très anciens d'ailleurs
on retrouve aussi dans le lean de rue
lopez pour faire une petite parenthèse
on trouve aussi la fidi dans alors ça
c'est assez étonnant avec quasiment les
mêmes début que dans le livre de
philidor d'ailleurs quasiment les mêmes
coûts jusqu'à jusqu'à assez loin bref
toujours est il qu'on est devant une
italienne donc ça varie et c'est la
première fois qu'on voit ça dans ce
championnat du monde
une ouverture joué ces derniers temps à
haut niveau fous ces cinq avec petit
rock cavaliers pts 6
on sort les pièces et maintenant voilà
détroit on joue pas les grandes
variantes de type gambie mora où les
ventes avec ces trois noms joue très
calme en fait enfin très calme ça paraît
comme ça peut bien sûr et dangereux on
consolide le centre et on va voir après
le plan que vous
les blancs alors ça ressemble en fait
beaucoup à l'espagnol et sous certains
aspects lors des six très bien et
l'arrêté l'envoi la c3 alors ça c'est un
coup qu'on voit souvent dans la rue au
ps justement le fou après va venir un b3
puis en c2 souvent et puis après on
jouera des d4
alors pour avant de jouer des quatre on
s'assure de bien contrôler la case des
cas pour éviter de se faire clouer le
cavalier parce que ce cavalier est très
important dans la mesure où on veut
jouer des 4 puisqu'il et contrôler cette
case empathie rock métal rouge et 5
rouges et 5
alors ça c'est c'est un coup responsable
oncle où le cavalier on reste se faire
chasser le fou mais on cloue le cavalier
pour on veut peut-être empêché les noirs
hommes 2e même poussé des 5 alors à
noter aussi que se clôt à gt est
d'autant plus intéressant quand le fou
ici ne peut pas justement s'opposer en
l'occurrence donc il est sorti on a joué
des six
donc c'est difficile de revenir donc
pour sortir de ce clown ça va pas être
simple il faut force faux s'affaiblir
avec axis g5 et donner des données de
des faiblesses un petit peu quelque part
on concède des faiblesses du côté roy
donc c'est ce que font les noirs h6
watch 4 et gsm
alors parfois on peut sacrifier un g5
avec le cavalier ça existe c'est sans
doute jouer dans cette position que laly
pranger scène puis on prend fou prend
parce que ça reste très difficile de
sortir du clonage
on va très vite que ensuite on peut
jouer trois roches un f4 pour ouvrir la
colonne f&a les gober le cavalier qui
est qui est cloué on peut aussi
simplement jouer qu'adam f3 qui renforce
le clouage mais nord peuvent tenir avec
roy g7
bref on peut sacrifier c'est possible
voilà c'est tout à fait jouable
bon c'est de la théorie on va pas
regarder ça mais c'est juste à noter que
c'est tout à fait jouable
foucher 3
sur ce type de cas de sacrifices non
seulement en un clouage très pénible
difficile à sortir mais en plus on a ne
serait ce que récupérer au moins deux
points
déjà pour la pièce ce qui est pas loin
d'être déjà très intéressant alors j'ai
quatre ça c'est un coup encore plus
responsable
assez étonnant de la part de nissan en
avance encore le pion ce qui fait qu'on
affaiblit et encore plus les loin mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile d'aller
profiter de cet affaiblissement étant
donné que le centre pour l'instant est
bloquée et nancy le synthé été ouvert
avec les fous qui peuvent jouer le roi
aurait aurait des soucis à se faire mais
là en l'occurrence temps que le centre
est fermé
pourquoi pas mais c'est quand même
risqué alors cavaliers h4 progressif
logique on vise plus tard la case f5 et
puis bon ben bien sûr on sort de la
prise alors à noter que se plonger 4 est
protégé par le câble et le site et par
le fou et par le foot imite donc ça
c'est ça c'est quand même il fan non ici
joue quand même de façon très active
mais c'est dangereux parce que
s'affaiblit et ça ça peut être bon pour
un aria mourihno eacute la kabbale et h5
alors voilà l'idée sans doute de la
chinoise elle joue cavalier h cinq
attaquants bien sûr j'ai 3 mais surtout
potentiellement elle pourra jouer plus
tard fcn alors pas tout de suite puisque
un clouage faudrait d'abord jouer le roi
alors c'est tout on ne sait pas évident
parce que si on veut ensuite quand on
joue avec cinq on se reprend qu'avec g6
avec une fourchette
bon mais alors bon c'est plutôt sans
doute pour échanger le fou que pour
pousser ses pions
même si plus tard ça pourrait être une
idée mais attention ça fait quand même
beaucoup de pure annoncé devant le roi
et c'est vrai qu'il est un peu à l'air
seront donc c'est plutôt pour aller à
gober ce fou tôt ou tard très bien à
noter aussi que les blancs sont
intuitives embêter avec ce fou qui très
puissant le pion f2 est flou et donc en
cas prises angers 3 on peut pas prendre
du pur f ce qui peut être intéressant un
parfois dans ce type de position puisque
ça ouvre la colonne f
mais sur sa même pu doubler en plus vers
l'extérieur de l'échiquier en termes de
structure de pions c'est pas une bonne
idée mais en terme d' attaques contre le
roi c'est tout à fait intéressant à 4
leur coup classique là aussi on se donne
un peu d'air à 4 on anticipe a6b 5
et puis on donne un peu d'air aux fous
si c'est à dire que le fou en cas
d'atteinte du cavalier pourrait venir en
a deux voilà il ya plus et lecavalier ne
fait plus rien et puis après on menace
aussi bekkat d'ailleurs à noter bon
voilà donc on prendre l'air ici et on se
ménage une case sur le fou parfois aussi
dans ce type de partie 4 à 5 et puis la
tour peut s'activer alors ici par an à 3
puis ce qu'elle fout c'est celle mais
peut-être en a quatre à condition que le
centre souverain bien sûr et qui la
traversent soit ouverte à 6 voilà alors
pareil pour les noirs un peu hein c'est
à dire que ce coup deux intérêts un jeu
peut préparer beaucoup plus tard un
c'est pour pour plus loin des 5
j'enlève la case b5 au blanc pourquoi
pas cercle cavaliers pourraient pas
venir sur son bassin pour sa main et
lycées anecdotique et surtout on se
ménagent la casa 7 pour ce magnifique
fou très puissant qui cloue le pion f2
donc empêche les blancs de monter une
attaque rapidement faudrait rejouer
watchers f3 pour ouvrir la colonne f
mais c'est jouable pour le faire je
pense aux acheteurs f3 pour forcer le
pas ce que l'art lennon sera obligée de
soin de prendre soin de laisser prendre
et donc d'ouvrir la colonne f se demande
d'ailleurs pourquoi les blancs ne font
pas et on va voir peut-être ils vont le
faire est bon mais ce fou il est bien
parce qu'en plus ils contrôlent la casse
des quatre centrales ici voilà donc
c'est un ciel magnifique une magnifique
pièce à un cahier à trois logiques on
sur la pièce alors à noter que ce
cavalier pourquoi ils sont trois alors
c'est aussi une des idées d'a4 à car non
seulement jean pesce b5
j'ai pris de l'air à l'aide à et aussi
je peux sortir lequel viendra trois
parce qu'en cas de prise
je peux reprendre de la tour si j'ai pas
joué à quatre shows obligés de prendre
du plomb et
georges et des pions vraiment mal future
a3 je veux aller en c2 regardez comme il
faut y penser avant quand même c'est 2,3
et voilà la case f5 puisqu'on aurait
deux cavaliers qui contrôle cette case
avec l'aide du pion cette case est
faible et donc on va viser la casse fait
l'on veut occuper cette case dame g5 g5
coût normal qu logique se fout étant un
petit peu museler non seulement on peut
le prendre quand on veut mais pour
l'instant il tape contre contre du mur
l'un contre un mur on peut mettre la
dame sur cases noires de façon de façon
safe quoi on n'a pas de problème
cavalier ces deux cas les c2 on vise 3
logique et pourquoi pas donc expliqué à
noter aussi qu'on pourrait maintenant
jouer des 4 un an maintenant que le
calibre alors le premier surtout des
cats et qu'après fois c'est bon ben on
est un peu coincé ce pion des quatre
seront peut plus jouer cavalier sinon on
des quatre est perdu voilà donc c'est un
peu un peu tendu à voir quand même alors
fois cette voie là anticipation alors là
la fée l'a déjà fait 1
lifan précédemment elle joue face est
déjà une partie ou la douche ou à 7
avant qu'on vienne l'attaqué se fout ce
cap s'il s'appelle coup prophylactique
star en cas de des 4 ou 2 b 4 bat le fou
n'est pas attaqué on peut on peut donc
répondre par un autre coup donc ça
anticipent cette poussée que les noirs
peuvent pas vraiment empêché on ne peut
pas empêcher b4 décati les blondes le
faire ils le font mais là ils gagneront
pas de temps sur le fou cavaliers 3,4
alors ça c'est responsable puisque ça
propose de donner un pion
alors qu'est ce qui se passe là parce
qu'il faut regarder quand même fou prend
1,3 puis on prend 1,3 et puis ben on va
gagner le pion échec tout petit peu
embêtant quand même alors là les blancs
pour y répondre par alors regarder sans
doute fou et f2 alors pas perdre de
temps la dame revient à angers 5
alors j'ai 3 d'abord pourquoi pour
empêcher les noirs de jauger 3 parce que
la regarder ici les noirs menace de
jouer j'ai 3 h francs et puis cave à
l'écran et il n'y a pas de problème les
blancs les noirs ont égalisé
tranquillement ils ont réussi il y
aurait en plus un pion on est de plus
mais là on va jouer trois pourquoi j'ai
trois noms se massant pêche mais en plus
ça enlève lacazette 4 cavaliers ce qui
fait ce qu'elle avait dit hors jeu et
maintenant on va jouer après par exemple
un coup comme
les métaux admettons vous aussi ce tout
à fait jouable et bien dans ce cas là on
jouerait alors sans doute fou prendre 6
préalable puis on prend 1,6 avec des
pions de doubler alors ont pour origine
un b3 tout simplement qui régale qui
regagne entre 6 c b6 alors c'est faux si
c'est peut-être pas idéal
il imagine un coût plus simples comme
fou en 17
juste pour voir les idées impossible et
là maintenant voilà un coup comme eux
alors dame
je pars d'un e 2 pourquoi pas d'un mais
de deux valeurs bien avec l'idée n'a
peut-être pas d'un mais de deux parce
que les noms auraient cavaliers quatre
attaques la dame et si on prend et
maintenant le club n'est pas perdu il
est protégé
c'est compliqué il semblerait que dans
maints soit un tout petit peu mieux fait
peu importe donc on va jouer faux et
trois attaques la dame et la chine s'y
attaquer voilà donc fait 3 on pourra
jouer la dame ensuite en d2 on va
augmenter la pression sur h6 la toa une
fois que le fouet la dame seront ici la
tour va jouer à fond on va pouvoir
doubler les tours le cavalier la sauter
f5
il ya une très grosse attaque en fait
voilà un voyez que fct faible h6 est
faible c'est ce qu'on avait dit refais
d'avoir pousser les pions voilà ici là
le jeu et c'est un peu ouvert et c'est
tout de suite dangereux
donc c'est pour ça que les blancs n'ont
pas peur de donner un pion même serais
très content que les noirs le prennent
contre de l'initiative
donc les noirs ne prennent pas et elle
joue car ie7 un coût beaucoup plus
tranquille solide regardez comme c'est
très positionnelle ce coup puisqu'on
contrôler la case f5 la fameuse case ou
et blanc ou en guise de poster un
un carrier ça c'est quand même à noter
compositionnel très intéressant
donc ici des 4 et blanc maintenant que
ben ils ont forcé les noirs finalement à
reculer et des 4 as encore plus fort
parce que il n'ya plus le cavalier qui
protège donc d4 on tue un peu l'action
de ce fou puisque maintenant il bute sur
un pion si les noirs près si les blancs
prennent ça peut ouvrir du jeu pour le
fou ici en g3 ça va obliger à les noirs
à se décider à le prendre et donc on
n'aura plus à se poser de questions ce
qui peut être intéressant
voilà donc c'est un coup logique on
essaie maintenant de s'attaquer au
centre si on arrivait à ouvrir le jeu
étant donné la position faible du roi
noir ça serait bon pour les blancs donc
là pas mal pour les blancs aussi
dangereux pour les noirs faut faire
attention d'alger sept coups défensifs
recul en g7 alors peut-être pour avoir
un oeil sur f7 puisque les blancs
peuvent aussi menacé des manoeuvres à
base de dames de f3 j'ouvre le jeu sur
la colonne f je visais vii
là je rajoute une défense en effet cette
je veux peut être aussi joué un coup
comme caballé g6 avec les noirs même si
non c'est pas terrible parce qu'il ya
une cabine et 5 qui va venir si si c'est
possible
17 et on secoue est pas facile à
analyser faut avouer donc des dames g7
ah bon il est pas un mauvais coup mais
c'est pas facile à comprendre
on a on a toujours un oeil sur eux c'est
à voilà on fait pression sur des quatre
voilà c'est ça l'idée les noirs font
pression sur des quatre c'est plus
cavalier c6 qui a taxé la dame prise
prises et hop dame prend des quatre
voilà donc ça oblige les blancs à se
décider là voilà c'est ça l'idée
d'amener cette ses forces et les blancs
se décider et on veut pas laisser les
blancs comme ça et ce pion des 400 sans
problème donc prise en 2005
hélas les noirs prennent d'abord le
oui prenant aux 5 on va essayer prenez
on peut d'abord le fln qui prône tout
d'abord en 50 quand ils veulent ils
peuvent prendre congé tron dans la prise
en sec donc là le pion des quatre ayant
disparu ce four et regarder tout de
suite ça y est il a de nouveau son rôle
voilà c'est difficile pour les blancs
d'envisager f3 pour ouvrir le jeu sur la
colonne f alors qu'avant ça pouvait
commencer à devenir tendancieux cette
histoire cavaliers f5
pourquoi passer leur alors le problème
c'est que les noirs contrôler
suffisamment donc après fou prend f5
alors on prend du fou ça permet de lier
les tours si on appris du carillon est
toujours un problème avec le pouce et 8
comment le sortir là on s'en débarrasse
ce qu'on sait pas où le mettre
et maintenant pions prends ça c'est
intéressant donc on double des pions
certes mais bon c'est un pion qui quand
même muselle un petit peu les noirs
regarder ça empêche définitivement un
coup comme f5
on peut menacer f67 certaines variantes
on va le voir d'ailleurs dans la partie
un petit peu et les blancs bombés les
blancs
clairement de l'avant si si ils ont plus
de pions avancer maintenant bon c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile quand même
augmenté la pression sur laurent noir
c'est noir de jouer et voilà up ou c5
alors l'idée de pousser 5 bat que ce fou
maintenant qu'il ya plus qu à rien de
3,1 bon pas forcément un rôle sur cette
colonne puisque les blancs veulent jouer
au rachat de façon tôt ou tard pascal de
leurs idées ça reste de jouer f3 puis on
prend un et deux façons comme ça la
tourte protégera f6 f5 et on menacera f6
avec fourchette d'un dhow cavaliers donc
là si on vient on sait 5
c'est en cas d'attaqué de ce fou
notamment c'est de pouvoir revenir en d6
voilà notamment en cas de dan 17 là il y
avait une menace blanche dans 17
attaques et lecavalier et me attaqué le
pion 6 est embêtant aussi donc lanka
d'amd c'est ton jour food et 6 et tout
tient ce fou est magnifique
voilà et on y lit pas facile à déloger
parce que le pion c'est n'ai pas pris
l'argent c'est ça qu'il faudrait jouer
d'avoir beckham et s'ils ont juste c4 a
pris b4 et emprise on sait très loin
d'aller attaquer le fou des six donc en
d6 il aura un rôle défensif clés et
contrôlera le pion aux scènes qui est
quand même crucial à noter aussi que les
noirs ont du mal à protéger suis en 5 1
pour ça que fout des fous c'est ça qui
est important parce que f si ce n'est
pas possible à cause du cloud âge il ya
le fou ici on regarde et qui attaquent
le roy on peut pas défendre avec le pion
là donc c'est quand même pénible et
mettre une tour c'est possible mais il
ya le cavalier 7 qui viennent donc voilà
donc c'est pas facile à défendre ce pion
non c'est presque le seul coup c'est
scène pour défendre le pion aux simples
c'est chaud l'un est là les blancs
semblent avait quand même un bel
avantage alors là à ce moment là les
blancs avaient une suite intéressante
regardez le il aurait pu jouer f6
attaque
avec aval et donc la prise du pion et
forcé et regardez maintenant la dame
peut prendre le pion g4 qui n'est plus
protégé par la dame adverse c'est c'est
un coup de sacrifice de déplacement
kouassi voulant déplace le monde et
place une pièce de façon à pouvoir
prendre une autre dame d'un projet
quatre échecs les noirs ici pour
rencontrer les chèques par très
certainement un coup comme dame gsm tout
simplement
et maintenant les blancs un coup comme
d'un f3 et on a plus de alors en a plus
depuis ont doublé les noirs façon
peuvent pas tout de suite joué f5 qui
serait dangereux puisque ça menacerait
f4 mais il ya toujours ce club qu'il
faudrait préparer donc est ce qu'on a le
temps de préparer c'est pas sûr c'est
pas simple imaginons coup comme le roi à
schwyz qui al'air keller jouable via les
blancs attaquerez les premiers sans
doute peut-être pas celle là mais celle
là tu aurais fait un je pense touré fin
attaque le pion aux 5 avec le fou menace
fou prend 1,5
voilà hélas les noirs sont juste soin de
jouer certainement joué foulée on veut
pas jouer 6 pourquoi on veut pas réussi
ça affaiblit la case aussi ce qui est
déjà contrôlée par le fou ça affaiblit
aussi la casse g6 qui est quand même un
saut de cavaliers l'un qui puise et un
seau potentiellement avec fourchette
même si ses protégés par la dame et
cavaliers c'est des cases qui à moyen
long terme vont s'avérer
des problèmes c'est des casses faiblesse
et si on peut éviter de se créer casse
faible c'est pas plus mal
donc plutôt un coup comme food et si si
si et les blancs voilà en maintenant
peuvent prendre au 17
voilà peut prendre bessette et on peut
commencer at actifs y ait tout ça et ça
peut être très intéressant
hélas là c'était là c'était vraiment
intéressant alors au lieu de quoi dans
cette position au lieu de jouer ce coup
ci ce qui était quand même intéressant
qui affaiblit c'est un peu loin on
prenait entre les g4 commencé à rouvrir
les lignes contre le roi on a vu qu'on
pouvait peut-être même nom créé des
problèmes assez tendue d'autant qu'on a
la paire de fou on aime bien ouvrir
alors ça forcera les noirs après en
danger 3 mais on reprendra du pion n'y a
pas de problème en attendant belle et
blanc ne joue pas ça il joue un coût
beaucoup plus prudent mais aussi
beaucoup moins tendue c'est sans doute
le coup là voilà suivant c'est toi alors
c'est pas un mauvais coup un tour un jeu
menace pour prendre 5 c'est pas rien
puisqu'on peut pas protéger avec le pion
ou alors se foutent obligé de reculer
mais alors préalablement ce que fait ou
ifan est encore plus simple
elle prend d'abord en g3 à son premier
point h 30 et maintenant oh ben ça y est
elle sort elle sort du cloud âge voilà
il ya plus de clouage donc ça peut être
intéressant à noter que les blancs aussi
dans certaines variantes ici un pouvait
menacer dans certaines variantes des
coups comme cavalier j-6 qu'avait léger
s'y attaquent la tour puisque le pion ne
peut pas prendre le cavalier et si les
noirs prennent on pourrait reprendre du
pillon alors tout de suite ça doit pas
être bon mais dans certaines variantes
ça peut être ça peut être dangereux donc
c'est pour éviter ça il vaut mieux
éviter d'avoir des pièces cloud et si on
peut c'est pas plus mal
on croit à schwyz est passé pas si mal
maintenant dames 2 pression sur cinq
d'accord pourquoi pas donc c'est un
autre plan et on voit que c'est moins
que vous voyez que c'est moins tendue
que la variante où on prenait le pion g4
m6 d'un projet cap puisque dans la
variante dans cet art là on avait une
position très asymétriques il y avait
pas de symétrie cercle à il y avait des
chaînes de pions qui était pas
équivalentes et à partir de là on il ya
des chances de guerre augmente plus est
symétrique plus c'est difficile de
gagner en fait voilà il faut créer de la
dissymétrie gabon mais marianne mesures
jouent plutôt pour l'instant des
positions des bons coups c'est pas des
mauvais coups bien sûr mais c'est moins
c'est moins fort à me semble fou des six
défend avec le fou c'est ce qu'on a dit
si longtemps qu'on peut retarder f 6 6
qui affaiblit les cases g6 et aussi cela
ces deux cases aussi cg 6 à la fois
contrôlé par le fou pour le fou après on
imagine le foin en sicile il est bien ce
fou et il est pénible pour les noirs
parce qu'on peut plus jouer la tour en
g8
voilà encore un peu peur et faire ainsi
ce pion à vii bouge ça donne beaucoup
d'air au fouet puis la casse g6 à tout
moment maintenant le cas à lille
pourrait venir faire un échec ça peut ça
peut ça peut être dangereux à long terme
donc ici dame e 4 alors qu'à 24 alors là
on comprend un peu l'idée à leucate
c'est pas mal regardez le roi là bon si
on pouvait venir avec l'entrée dans
l'âge 7 avec le fou en d3 envoyée voilà
imaginez que le foot soit en d3 c'est
aux blancs de jouer f6 fourchette les
noirs près d'1 up damas est mat on y
part un mais on comprend que la dame ici
peut faire une batterie est d'autant que
la dame ici attaque bessette voyez alors
c'est la même idée que tu à l'heure mais
sans cette idée qu'on avait deux d'avoir
pris le pion j'ai eu ce fameux point g 4
et là on l'a pas pris et en a on n'a pas
donné de 6 c'est curieux c'est dommage
qu'elle ait pas je fais cette vente
tourbe est vite tombée 8 alors solide
très solide de la part de gloire tout
simplement celtique ou qu'il faut pas
négliger ça al'air l'an puisque la tohu
on se lie bron en de 8 les pâtes et riz
mais si si elle est très bien un bien
sûr ça défend 17 mais surtout si à
regarder le potentiel de pousser là ici
poussez b5 apprend b prend apprend le
foot attaquer et après b4 et voilà cette
oreille et tout de suite qu'elle est
tout de suite très forte donc si elle
est très forte chute à la poussée qui
gagnent des temps parce que ça attaque
des pièces elle est donc très forte
ambiguïté
voilà faut pas croire qu'elle est
passive parce que derrière un pion se
tient immobile et donc cette tour on
attend que ça le bon moment pour pousser
b5 faut 2 alors ça sans doute un mauvais
coup alors on met sur sa tâche et 4 bon
maintenant ici les blancs pouvaient
quand même temps tu es fou détroit avec
au minimum la menace m6 gagne la partie
puisque le cavalier est attaquée fin
gagne la partie
si parce que la dame est attaqué aussi
il faut prendre avec la dame
sinon on perd une pièce et c'est matt
bon mais là les noirs auraient pu
répondre non surtout pas par sa bien sûr
mais par cavalli g8 calais j'évite tout
simplement puisque maintenant km 6 elle
est tout simplement je peux prendre du
cavalier tout est protégé n'y a pas de
problème c'est pas c'est pas forcément
top mais c'est pas mauvais pour les
blancs dans cette position pas très bons
non plus bien aimé s'est pas mouillé
bref au lieu de quoi bon fouet deux bon
pourquoi pas sa tâche des 4 mai après la
réponse quasiment forcé des noirs h5 qui
peinent mauvaise réponse je protège ses
quatre c'est logique mais sur ses pions
soit avancée mais c'est pas facile
d'aller acheter d'aller attaquer la base
ici 2
2 j'ai cassé des rages 5 comment on va
attaquer h50 on peut pas tout simplement
c'est impossible
la colonne h est ouverte mais comment on
met une tour là c'est pas possible le
roi s'il aura bien h 2e tour h13 j'ai un
ouais mais alors c'est long et puis en
plus ce cas il peut pas bouger s'il
bouge
eh bien il est pris il est pris en j'ai
6 ans rêve cinq idées sur son pion et en
f3 et les prix et angers 2 il ya sur son
pion c'est un des problèmes aussi de
cette partie pour mariam ou zouk c'est
que ce cavalier ici il est un peu un pur
jeu donc la bombe elle joue un coup
logique quand même tu auras des uns doit
toujours position solide pas de problème
on écoute un peu curieux mais mais
finalement mais bon une bonne position
quand même mais âge là elle a pas réussi
à créer de vrais problèmes en noir 1
pour l'instant cavalier vite replacé
pièces ou lifan c'est très joli câble et
j'ai vite je veux venir un f6 attaqué la
dame voyez aussi l'intérêt pas avoir
joué six c'est aussi de se préparer
cette manoeuvre en rêve si ce que les
bots puisque il est devant le pion au f5
ce qui le bloque donc si ce pion f5 et
bloquer baisse et le caillage 4 qui est
bloqué aussi puisqu'il pourra jamais
venir en jeu de la partie lui va pas
bouger donc 4e 6 la dame va être attaqué
en plus il est derrière un pion très
difficile attaqué ce cavalier et il
prépare la menace en famille peut aider
à pousser au 4 le 4 est intéressant
puisque pas facile à attaquer aux quatre
surtout vu que le foot hand maintenant
il faut c'est très long ckb 3 ces deux
pour l'attaqué ce pion et puis qui plus
est les noirs peuvent le protégé par les
tours et anjou un casse je libère les la
puissance de la dame sur les cases
noires et le sel du fou aussi les cases
noires s'ouvre un peu même si je tape
sur des dossiers 3 il ya rab et scène
plus tard subi de b4 on va casser ça et
les cases noires vont être fortes pour
les noirs oui ça a l'air de rien c'est
positionnelle mais à long terme ça peut
être très dangereux rouages de hall
alors ça je pense ça c'est le plus
mauvais coups de la partie pour
l'instant
proche de alors moi je pense être très
très mauvais parce que le roi ici il est
mal placé en vue d'une finale bah il
n'est pas en jeu il peut pas venir en
jeu par h3 puisqu'il ya le psg 4 s'il ya
une finale plus tard il faut absolument
qu'ils sont aux anges et 1 et soit il
vient en jeu par f1 à eux deux soit
éventuellement s'il le faut a disparu en
un jour en f3 et puis reiff 2 mai donc
si le fou et là c'est plus dur hein
parce que sur f3 bon si le pion à bouger
fou qui attaquent g3 puis en plus il
peut se prendre un essai et un échec ans
et 5 mai il peut venir paraître femme
est en tout cas un rouage de à mon avis
c'est très très bon et il est très mal
placée sous l'impression qu'on a on a un
coût d'attentes ici qui est pas bon
puisque c'est au noir de jouer et de nom
ils ont des coûts dame g5 adam revient
au g5 elle a fini son travail 1 rappelez
vous l'été venir g7 on avait dit c'était
pour faire pression sur des quatre la
force et les blancs à prendre maintenant
1 revient au g5 contrôle des cases
noires c'est bien ça
voilà on contrôle bien contrôler tout lé
bien cette dame regarder quels contrôles
plus de cases ici que angers7
vous pouvez aussi placer vos pièces
avaient ce simple critère est ce que
j'ai pas une case où je contrôle plus de
kasbah c'est le cas ici on gsm contre le
plus quand g7 et après je peux jouer car
il y six attaques la dame
à noter aussi regarder que le cavaliere
qui sera complémentaire à la fois du fou
de la dame il contrôlera les cases
blanches du centre le centre est aux
mains des noirs bizarrement voilà c'est
ça qui va se passer
regardez fou c4 regardez le four revient
ces quatre noms c'est quand même un aveu
de faiblesse c'est que c'est cool
affreux de fou c4 est un rouage de ces
dommages
là vraiment raté quelque chose à ma
musique tout est la position là et
commence à être difficile à jouer pour
les blancs cavalli m6 faut que la dame
joue et voilà regarder les noirs
contrôle le centre avec le cavalier y
contrôler deux cases blanches
le fou contrôle bien sûr défend le pion
aux scènes qui lui-même attaques des 4 a
contrario le cavalier h4 il et il est
mort ce qu'a manière dames 3 maintenant
les blancs propose un échange de dalles
mais ces avantages des noirs dans prend
tout reprend rien de décisif et on voit
bien que balla les le jeu a changé de
camp là c'est à dire c'est bien et c'est
bien au noir maintenant de pouvoir faire
quelque chose c'est qu'on l'initiative
maintenant il faut qu'ils ont consolidé
leur jeu nous sans doute avec le roi
angers7
plus tard protéger f7 ce qui va libérer
la tour parce que pour l'instant c'est
la tour bouge mais sur le fou attaque s
est donc simplement on va d'abord
protège espion ensuite on a centralisé
les tours soit sur la colonne des soit
peut-être d'abord en pillant des
peut-être et on va aussi jouer b5 bk
pour affaiblir ce côté-là ouvrir la
colonne de la tour alors que les banques
qu'est ce qu'ils font avec le roi h 2 le
cavalier en h4
c'est pour ça que c'est important de
prendre ce pion g4 qu'on a me dit tout à
l'heure ça donnait de l'air notamment
cavaliers et regarder si le pion g4
était pas là ils auraient pu revenir en
jeu quand il voulait par f3 et à il est
complètement veut tout le temps tu sais
triste alors une petite idée quand même
un pur pas donné tous du côté noir ici
le roi h2 un tout petit peu intéressant
dans la mesure où ils protègent et 3
donc on peut envisager de jouer f 3 1
mais si on joue aux 3,1 peux même pas
prendre si on prend g4 c'est le cavalier
qui met au g4 avec un jeu superbe bonfim
bref
on peut même reprendre du pur de toute
façon donc on peut reprendre du pillon
et les six cavaliers h4 hors jeu bref
c'est pas bon mauvais plan e4
alors ça c'est un coup de grands maîtres
un très difficile à trouver leucate
alors le cavalier l'année pas prenable
ce câble est hors jeu on l'a dit pourra
jamais gagner en jeu et il est mort en
plus un joueur de classe c'est encore
plus dur de d'envisager de le mettre en
estrie un jour ce qu on peut pas
l'attaquer non plus avec le fou donc qui
contrôle ici la case de quatre ont joué
au cas pourquoi b1 j'empêche le
doublement des tours j'empêche aussi fou
détroit voilà je prends des cases je
prends les cases blanches alors que mon
fou regarde et en plus maintenant il est
mal placée ce projet trop et cloud est
bon c'est rien de grave a priori mais
bon vous voyez quand on enlève des
cazoulins en voici saaq et le problème
c'est que c'est très difficile de
maintenant de trouver des cases en fait
autour d'eux voilà on recule avec la
tour parce que si on veut doubler ben on
pouvait pas le faire un des 3 par
exemple
qui plus est en trois ans n'était sous
la prise de deux fous ces cinq qui
attaquent la tour bon mais au moins là
on joue 1 2 c'est là aussi c'est prend
un petit tu peux prophylactique aussi
n'ont pas roulé cette tourbe et des huit
donc les noirs abandonnent toute idée de
jouer b5
bon maintenant que la dame est plus là
bas bon tout ça bon peut-être n'y a pas
d'idée bon voilà on joue encore mieux on
évite d'affaiblir envoyons n'affaiblit
pas en fait ils ont suffisamment
affaibli de l'autre côté puis maintenant
ça s'avère an plus tôt fort en une
pression moins ici on affaiblit
parallèle dames on va on va essayer de
centraliser les pièces en fonte b3 alors
l'idée de fouler 3 après certainement
poussé deux et faire le siège du pion du
pion aux quatre tours 17
alors tour 17 maintenant je peux soit
doublée sur la colonne des soies faire
autour de huit tours sète doublé sur la
colonne voilà je choisis ou s'ils jouent
double donc ici les blancs qui
choisissent maintenant de jouer 3 c'est
l'heure
le problème c'est bien sûr ce cavalier
ce cavalier n'a qui n'a pas de gaz ont
joué trois en espérant que les noirmont
prendre prendre prendre on reprend du
cavalier ouf on peut respirer maintenant
on est bien sur les noirs vont pas faire
ça ils vont laisser les blancs avec ce
quart est horrible alors tout d'abord
regarder
la très jolie taux à 8 à noter que la
tour 17 aussi protège le pion initiative
donc on n'a pas joué roger 7 mai c'est
la tour qui protège alors tour 8 bat est
déjà bon mais du coup je surprotège le
pion aux quatre en cas de prise en main
4 après les échanges le truc c'est
toujours pareil ce cavalier il est paumé
il est au centre
à noter aussi que prisent tour prat en
tout reprend cavale et prend en plus le
pion g3 serait en prison
on peut difficilement le défendre alors
tours 2-1 et simplement tour des huit
voilà à toi problème
en plus cela maintenant qu'on a joué la
tour 7 on a doublé le fou contrôler la
case hausse est donc en cas de prise des
noirs n'y a pas de perte de tours prise
prise pour trois ans fou prend tout
tient donc en plus et doubler et il ya
plus de
il est le plus haut 4 n'est pas vraiment
de cloud et quoi qu'on aimerait qu'il le
soit donc la foule c2a y est là c'est
l'erreur alors ça a l'air de rien mais
ce coûtent ces coûts est une faute on va
voir on va voir on va voir d'abord à la
partie puis on va voir en quoi un autre
coup aurait évité ce qui est pas évident
une belle combinaison à la clé regardez
maintenant les noirs simplement prennent
en f3 et après tout reprendre cette
comprendre cette tour prend 1,7
regardez superbe f2 aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe regard des classiques la
tour ici on la reprend pas à noter qu'il
ya même pas d'échec à rien du tout mais
de toutes façons ne peut pas empêcher
enfin on peut aussi on peut empêcher par
food et 3 c'est le seul coup c'est un
coup intermédiaires et maintenant les
noirs simplement prennent 7 et
simplement belle et blanc n'ont pas
réussi leur coup de libérer leurs
cavaliers lecavalier paumé le roi est
coupé de fin complètement bloquée ce pur
avec deux en fait bloc toutes ces pièces
qui peuvent pas bouger
ce qui fait que les noirs jouent avec
deux pièces de plus trois pièces de plus
même puisque le roi noir lui va pouvoir
jouer les trois pièces de plus dans
cette position en fait voilà c'est ça
qu'il faut analyser parce que tous à la
hune complètement bloquée regardez c'est
impossible de sortir de là le fou ne
peut rien faire en plus il tape sur son
propre client il ne sert à rien ce fou
juste à empêcher de faire dame qui plus
est les noirs peuvent gagner très vite
en jouant cavalier e 4 suivi de cavale
et des deux et on va faire dame et on va
gagner le fou mais on n'est même pas
pressé je suis sûr qu'on peut jouer à
l'euro - 30 kg devant la mener on fait
ce qu'on veut la regarder comme c'est
complètement bloquée c'est horrible
alors c'est à partir on va y revenir
alors tour 17
maintenant imaginons que les blancs et
jouer un coup comme fou à 2
voilà possibilités alors dans ce cas là
si les noirs avaient pris c'est pas tout
à fait la même parce qu'il y aurait tout
reprend tout reprendre tout reprend
regarder les c'est très joli info faut
regarder ça et là si les noirs jouent la
fameuse f2 menace da ba je vais pas je
me fous ces quatre regarder je vais
faire tout reprend f7 et là je menace
tant sur enjeux menace fou c4 mais je me
laisse pas que ça alors regardez
maintenant le simple enfin les vidant
maintenant fait la suite c'est bien sûr
bête alors là je fais dame alors dans ce
cas la dame et noir sont gagnants et non
merdé superbe cave allégé six échecs à
regarder skalecki pouvait pas jouer on
apprit purifie 7 et on l'avait dit tout
à l'heure ce qualité un coup de faire
échec
maintenant regardez le roi est en échec
à noter que ce roi n'a qu'une case
maintenant ici et regardez le faut howie
oui qu'est ce qu'on se dit là bas on
peut simplement bouger la tour alors par
exemple le tour en deux sets et c'est
matt regarder parce que lecavalier
contrôler les deux cas ces fuites et la
houppe où je tienne tous superbe
nat alors les noirs peuvent encore
donner dame c4 on prend la dame
le cavalier on prend le cavalier seimat
voilà c'est juste il faut donner toutes
les pièces et on est quand même mat
donc voyez fous ces deux il ya plus
cette contre attaque en cas de prise en
f3 du coup les noirs prennent en f3
ainsi la partie tout reprend tout
reprend tout reprendre 7 et le la
mauvaise nouvelle eve de la maille musi
troupe s'est quand même fait ici dominés
là c'est pas fini elle a encore joué
tout reprend yves cette dame est là il
ya plus de maths parce qu'en cas d' il
ya bien sûr en échec angers 6 elle va le
faire au g8
et maintenant bah alors si les noirs
vais jouer si les blancs avaient joué le
coup qui semble faisable
regardez four b3 la food & trois menaces
maths c'est qu'on est intéressant
d'accord alors là il faut être précis
regardez les noirs avaient ici fou
pranger trois échecs en plongée 3 et
forcé ya pas d'autres coûts et
maintenant cavalier de quatre échecs
échec d'accord alors maintenant regarder
si le roi vient en h4 boom
oh le beau matt superbe alors ça c'est
vraiment très très beau match le
cavalier protège les cases g5 et g3 donc
le roi ne peut pas y aller et le puy
c'est le pillage scène qui contrôlent g4
voilà et l'adami surkiffé matin alors là
c'est quand même un superbe matin du
couloir comme ça sur la banda en plein
milieu de partie alors à noter aussi qu
ici alors donc reprend et fort ses
cavaliers ou quatre échecs roi alors
attendez roi empêche de l'autre coup
d'accord mais dans ce cas là c'est aussi
matt puisqu'on va avoir j'ai trois
échecs et en fait maths
voilà donc c'est pour ça que après roy
g8
issifou b3 ne marche pas parce qu'il ya
une attaque de maths parfois quand j'ai
trois alors les blancs ici ils font tout
reprend m6 alors attention attention
attention c'est quand même triki comme
comme dirait l'autre
ce type de position maintenant on peut
envisager de faire des fouilles b3 et
peut-être des menaces mais surtout là
les menaces d'attaqués marche plus il y
en a plus le cavalier voyez que dans le
match on avait besoin du cavalier non
classé on pourrait se dire bon peut-être
les noirs vont venir mais enfin on voit
bien que ce fou lindon on me disait que
le rouage de était mal placé on l'avait
dit dès le début il ya le pion g3 ici
c'est quand on war de jouer et puis se
regarder ce roi surtout bas il n'y a pas
de case il a pas de casse donc c'est un
simple échec fait maths alors comment je
peux faire regarder très simplement ici
dit fan joue ouf
tous ces cinq à toi et seimat
ici ça va être ma part d'alger matt les
blancs peuvent rien faire y'a pas de mal
de leur côté y'a rien à faire il n'y a
pas de perpétuels ya rien du tout sûr
car hélios est simplement échecs ont
fait roi g7 au regard des cavaliers aux
sept g7
il reste l'atout est attaqué il reste ça
échecs et maintenant il suffit d'aller
en h7 est c'est fini il ya maths et plus
d'échecs là plus rien depuis on empêche
la tour de poing faire en échec la
découverte seimat forcé ici en juin mais
non faut pas avoir peur des fantômes ici
donc après fou c'est simple l'autre
l'autre échec possible c'est de jouer
sous b 3 échecs pour essayer de s'en
sortir mais simplement roi g7
ils restent ici le seul échec cet
orifice cet échec maintenant roi h6 et
c'est fini l'appui des chèques c'est
terminé donc le mat est imparable
donc après fou ces cinq egrem maria ou
zouk renverse son roi abandonne serre la
main de son adversaire et donc à les
mener 2 0
elle menait 2 0 qui puise elle a perdu
ici avec les blancs et donc c'était
c'était c'était la sixième partie donc
il ne reste plus que quatre parties pour
remonter deux points en finale de
championnat du monde
bon ce type de remontée c'est ça j'ai
quasiment jamais eu lieu quand rien on
peut se rappeler peut-être d'un une
remontée spectaculaire de karpov face à
kasparov et finit par perdre quand même
le match mais bon c'est ça reste des cas
vraiment exceptionnel bon c'est tout est
possible bien sûr toujours mais on voit
mal on voit mal comment maria masycheva
pouvoir maintenant s'en sortir je crois
qu'elle a raté comme les opportunités
dans cette partie la joue un peu trop
prudent elle aurait pu prendre ce pion
g4 un moment donné c'est que c'est ce
qu'il fallait faire
fall essayer de rentrer dans cette
position complexe asymétrique où les
blancs étaient bien les habits du jeu et
je pense que là elle avait de quoi
espérer faire quelque chose au lieu de
quoi la joue trop prudent les noirs ont
solidifié leur position consolidée ont
joué les bons coups positionnelle pour
bien bien protégé le centre attendre le
moment pour remonter revenir et profiter
de la mauvaise position du cavalier de
la mauvaise position du roi ce coup-ci
rouages de kepa bon voilà donc voyez des
petites imprécisions l'absence de prise
de risque au moment clé et à la fin on
perd la partie
voyez donc ne pas prendre de risques
c'est aussi risqué de peyrens et c'est
bien le problème
si on ne m'aime pour faire mieux il faut
prendre des risques parfois et il faut
un moment donné tu hantes et tenter des
choses parce que si on est que passifs
et bien voilà voilà ce qui arrive donc
super party quand même de la part des
noirs un coût attendu attendu attendu le
bon moment qu'ils ont redéployé leurs
pièces on l'a vu ce cavalier superbe qui
a lieu sept recalés g8 qualif 6 et et à
la fin le bo rien on ne peut que
constater que le centre et au maine et
noir voilà donc championnat du monde qui
tourne à l'avantagé du wif alors c'est
pas surprenant puisque degrés quand même
favorite de loin sur le plat puis sur le
papier mais bon on en espérait peut-être
championnat plus plus tendue voilà ça va
ce risque se finir avant avant la 10e
partie voilà merci de m'avoir suivi donc
pour cette sixième partie du championnat
du monde 2016 féminin et donc nous donne
quand même
et vous met sur pour la septième partie
au revoir